thanks everybody so this is gonna be a
very hands-on sort of tutorial as I
think anything with d3 should be so I'm
not sure how you can read this very well
but please go and grab this you'll find
perhaps a little boring if you don't I'm
going to keep this up for a few minutes
while I kind of give a bit of a a pretty
picture show of where we'll get to by
the end of today so grab that to grab
that github repo and what we'll be
talking about today is using d3 right
within the Jupiter notebook as opposed
to using kind of Python packages that
right to d3 I put it in the notebook
we're actually going to be able to kind
of do whatever you could imagine
possibly doing in d3 we'll do that right
in right in the notebook so examples of
you know highly interactive animated
graphs with different elements and
whatever you could imagine you can you
can do well this is this is in the repo
we'll get to it
other examples I come from an
architecture background so sometimes I
like to kind of crazy random spatial
things so this is an example of kind of
a space filling algorithm that I worked
out in Python I want to be able to see
how I look in JavaScript so that I can
then kind of post it on a web page or
whatever so this is kind of a mix of of
Python code in JavaScript producing this
space flowing thing at the end and you
can see it kind of as it as the
algorithm evolves that well yet this
part is in JavaScript and then you can
go in and manually tweak things if you
want to afterwards so things will be
very difficult to imagine doing in a
kind of our standard Python packages and
we won't be restricted to just d3 all
talking mostly about d3 today but there
are a lot of other kind of JavaScript
it's hard to see the watch out there but
this is exploring a graph with Sigma J s
which is another kind of JavaScript
package for looking at just only that
graphing package or you know graphs and
nodes and edges there's a nice little
package and we'll just show how you can
do that as well
okay so is everybody managed to get the
github repo anyone struggling with it
we're good and back awesome
okay okay so well this is what we're
going to talk to you today we'll talk
about why you don't want to do this
which is most of the time I will talk
about when you might want to do this
we'll dig a little bit deeper than you
would think into actually just we're
start at any show of hands how many
people here use d3 on a semi-regular
basis okay that's roughly what I
expected how many people use Jupiter
here on a regular basis okay yeah so
this is I'm I'm glad I'm speaking to the
relative so we'll actually dig into a
little bit of what d3 does and how it
will interact with your Jupiter notebook
and so that means getting into the Dom
and then we'll go through those of you
that don't use d3 right now don't worry
there's an awesome
collection of examples of you'll be able
to cut and paste things and use and then
kind of figure out how to tweak them
over time introduce you to those and the
blocks set up and then we'll dig into a
couple of examples
super simple example which is odd so we
say yeah you can do all these magic
things and then I'm going to show you
how to do a scatter plot but we'll start
there and then we'll go through a couple
of examples to show you kind of where
things will get tricky and then we'll
finally get back into this so you can do
whatever you want it's kind of kind of
world and we'll we'll get into some
discussion from there okay so why would
you want to do this sometimes but not
all the time we'll start with why you
wouldn't want to do it all the time
because most of the time what you really
want to plot is a scatter plot or some
bar chart or something and you there are
amazing tools for that
sometimes what you want to do is just
produce something to export to a - to a
web page or something and there are
great tools for that you can use MPL d3
or bouquet or whatever there are plenty
of ways to do this for most of the
things you'd want to do so if you have a
particular visualization that you this
fairly standard let's say and for which
there are there are kind of packages
that will let you do that very easily
use those don't do it I'm about to show
you unless you're really into d3 but
sometimes you may actually just want to
have that sort of flexibility you might
want to be able to you have let's say so
for me as a data scientist I often find
that I have I spend 95% of my
visualization time doing extremely
simple things and then I want to have
one really good money graph that I want
to be able to show at the end of the day
that says here's what this thing is
here's what here's the awesome part of
this so I tend to I tend to spend most
of my time doing kind of matplotlib type
plots and then really digging into one
at the end and so here if you're that
kind of person this would be a cool
trick for you to build to have in your
tool box it's also potentially handy I
think in some cases if you're working
with a front-end developer who's doing
some d3 things and you want to kind of
work through how that data flow is going
to happen in your flask backend there's
something we want to kind of integrate
all that into a Jupiter notebook when
you're starting out this is one possible
way to do that
that's for some other things you was you
might find that there's you know you saw
some really awesome graphic in the block
somewhere and you just wanna be able to
use that without doing much to it in
that case that may also be a useful use
case for here but generally this is not
for your everyday kind of stuff maybe
probably not probably not for anyone who
just came they just got in please
download this this repo will go through
it today and just a little heads up
before digging I'm going to get into for
those of you who aren't be three people
aren't friend end developers you might
glaze over a little bit here for the
first bit please stick with it as much
as possible it'll make it a lot more
useful at the end I'll show you that
there's we've developed this little
libraries of strong word there's like a
single script that kind of embeds a lot
of the stuff that we'll talk about so
that you can fairly easily kind of add
things and and play with it so if you
get lost just kind of stick with as much
as you can and hopefully we'll make
sense of it in the end
okay everybody has the notebook or the
sets of notebooks every wants to dig in
okay let's start with the first one to
look at is the hallo domme notebook and
I encourage you all at this point if
you're using to find the you want to
find the development tools part of your
browser that will let you see see what
roughly what you're seeing here so this
is in in Chrome I believe it's under
this under view I think and then there's
something developer tools somewhere down
in there Firefox is a similar thing and
that's what this lets you do is AC
console outputs from JavaScript which is
really handy if you're doing any sort of
debugging it also lets you just kind of
see what's happening yep
it's very hard to see there I'm not sure
if I can sorry
yeah the what most I'll try to the
important things within the look like
you can't read these things for example
or these yeah that's probably okay I'll
try to like focus on the really the kind
of key things you'll need but just if
you can get something in your browser
that that lets you see the Dom that
would be pretty handy is anyone know
what I mean with this at all I see a few
nods okay if someone's lost and someone
else is not in please help the person
that's that's it's there yeah maybe yeah
let me
oh now you don't see this at all
sorry but I guess okay so now you can
see this is okay in in Chrome if you go
to view developer developer tools you
should get something like this that pops
up this is looking at the console right
now if you look at the elements you can
see where where the things are this
little handy trick if you go to the this
will let you kind of pick anything in
the in the web page essentially and it
will show you where that thing sits in
the Dom okay so that the Dom stands for
document object model is effectively
when you write HTML you could think of
it as your kind of writing you're
writing a document that will be viewed
it'll be parsed and another stood by the
web page that can be changed over time
by your JavaScript and so what the 3
does and what and most JavaScript I just
do essentially you're modifying this
down over time so you can think of it as
it's kind of an XML tree structure
you're gonna add nodes you're going to
take away nodes you're going to be doing
things within the DOM and so kind of
being able to see what that means is
pretty handy along the way here
okay sorry if that's let's gonna move
along here so what Jupiter has this one
really kind of undervalued I think
function that most of this talk is
actually just going to be about wow look
there's this really cool function that
gives you direct access to the DOM and
that is in the ipython that core display
module there are a number of things to
give you access to the simplest one is
this HTML function and what that does
essentially is you if you if you write
HTML followed by a string it will
interpret that string and essentially
put it into the Dom right where the
output of this thing here is so if you
kind of look through how this document
is structured you'll find that there are
elements that correspond to the kind of
the input field they'll correspond to
the output field the output field that
is the rendered output that's where when
you when you write in this HTML function
it will it'll put that element into
there so you can write HTML strings in
this case we're just writing a a header
to with this particular text it will get
it'll get interpreted as a header with
that particular text in the in the Dom
next things you can add then to where
you can add style tags to that so you
can start by kind of manipulating so in
this case you have the same Dom element
we added a class to it that class
reference is a style and so the style in
this case is just giving the color of
that dump element and lastly you can add
scripts that will modify this over time
so in this particular case this this
HTML was just writing that too to the
Dom in this particular place as you as
we did before it's adding a style
element we're saying this is the the the
class I'm giving it an ID so that I can
reference it from the JavaScript and
then the script so originally when I
wrote that thing in there I originally
wrote in hello Dom and then the
JavaScript comes along and it's going to
change that text in this
to something else so this kind of
pattern of we're going to start with
something with with an object that we're
going to put into the Dom we're gonna
use JavaScript to change it this is what
we'll be doing throughout here and so
where DS 3 fits into all this d3 is just
a way of it's a pretty clever library
for helping you to modify the Dom with
data so the kind of pattern that that
gets used in d3 is you take so you
select a collection of Dom elements so
maybe you in your selecting a bunch of
hetero slits say through that selection
then you attach data to that so now you
have an array of elements that you've
selected and you have some array of data
we're going to then modify that array of
elements based on that data so it ends a
super simple concept that ends up being
extremely powerful within d3 and so
that's what we'll be doing will
essentially be sending a rays of data
that will modify the Dom through d3 yeah
if you sit under everything above it
yeah it should yeah that's it that's all
it's is everybody else is the sheets
working for everybody else ok ok so then
with d3 it's just it's just JavaScript
don't be afraid of it and that this is
an example of the same sort of thing
we're going to have we're going to start
by adding some styles we're going to use
the Styles in in a div that we're going
to add and then we're going to add a
script that script is going to specify
some data it's going to attach that data
to everything of a particular types
we're going to select some stuff attach
some data to it and then we're going to
change that that based on the data so in
this case we had
which we're setting the size based on
this data array that we had so they were
setting the size of our with our string
outputs and then the the kind of one
last little step which is a little bit a
little bit quirky what we'll do is to
kind of connect this back to the jupiter
notebook as we're actually just going to
write our data from jupiter into that
string that we're going to send to the
script there are a lot of different ways
that you could do this in some ways this
is kind of the roughest janky astray of
doing it but it means that this sheet
that you pronounce this document will
work as expected went on and be notebook
or NB viewer it will it's it makes it
just makes things a little easier if you
kind of write it directly into the
JavaScript we can talk about later if
those who want to talk about different
ways of doing this but this is there's a
simplest way of doing it so a little
brief review if you're lost don't worry
that was the worst of it it's gonna get
better
essentially this thing this HTML this is
your friend that's the main part if you
take away from this that's will be using
is that that writing into the Dom what
we do with that is that it's actually
adding Dom elements at that place in the
in the notebook will will add style
elements that lettuce changed colors and
such things will be adding of elements
which then let us add SVG elements and
other things magic things within d3 and
then we'll add scripts that will change
that over time this is all great
yeah Wow but why are we writing text I
thought we were talking about
visualization this is silly
so this is for those that haven't seen
these things that are amazing you're
going to love them this is in the blocks
world so if you go to d3.js org that's
one way to get to them you can see all
these incredible visualizations of this
and that and whatever you can also just
go straight to blocks Mike Bostock has
some pretty amazing ones and you'll see
what you get with these
is a usually a pretty picture of how the
thing works it's usually interactive a
little description maybe of what it is
and then you get code that you can
actually just download copy paste do
whatever you need to do with it and that
should work right out of the box so if
you take a block pulled out in the HTML
pull down whatever data that's
associated with it put it on your
desktop click on that index.html it will
pop up in your browser and boom you have
this this thing so this is what we'll
we'll kind of use to make this
transition we'll take some blocks we'll
figure out how to modify them a little
bit so that we can use them in the
notebook and what's kinda nice about
that is that there is this pretty
amazing array of visualizations out
there that if you might find useful for
what you're doing so our first example
is a scatter plot sure why not do a
super simple scatter plot this is from
the iris data set that every data
scientist has seen at least we should do
some sort of like graph of how often we
see this thing so there's a particular
block this one here and I'm actually
just going to switch back to digging
into the notebook here show you
and of course I might not have internet
working here but this if anyone does you
can just click on that link it'll show
you what the block looks like and what
we'll do here it should be pretty
obviously just kind of cut and paste so
just we'll walk through this a little
bit okay so you'll see your main your
main thing you need here of course is
that awesome that HTML export will also
use this the template command there also
many ways that you could do this as well
but this is just to get our data into
the string that we're going to write
into the script that will get read by
the HTML I prefer to download d3 and use
it locally you could also just reference
the there's a seat but plenty of CD ends
that host d3 the problem I'm finding
with that is that if you use a hosted
version of d3 and then you post it
somewhere it doesn't necessarily get
viewed right away or if someone opens
the notebook
it might be empty like the d3 things
don't show up it'll say d3 is not found
whatever so it's best to kind of host it
locally if you can but it still works
for what you're doing if you for most of
what you're doing if you use the CDN
okay so this case this this this sepal
length this irish data set you can grab
from one of a million different places
obviously here's one of them will read
that into to a data frame
I guess one important one kind of trick
of this is that usually most of those
blocks you'll find are expecting that
the data comes in in a certain way so
you kind of need to match the data that
you have to the data that's expected in
that block so usually it ends up being
an array of dicks and so one kind of
handy thing is just to take the in
pandas just use this to dict
records will usually get you into the
form that that is kind of asked for in
in the d3 code so from the blocks did it
load no if you just copy the CSV so if
you're looking at the block you'll see
the first part of it is there's a style
tab or a style section essentially just
take that whole section you can you can
copy it into this this area the trickier
one is the JavaScript part so there'll
be another kind of section the bottom of
the block that shows the the JavaScript
again you can take that copy it in we'll
talk later about other ways to make this
a little bit less kind of janky but it
helps to see it here a couple of things
that will change just these widths
you can modify those to kind of better
suit your your screen resolution if you
get really you can fancy you can
actually reference the Dom element that
that you're writing to and then have it
changed the width accordingly the other
thing you're going to need to change
when you go from a block to using this
in d3 so you'll need to instead of so it
d3 will will be looking for a particular
Dom element to it to write things to and
usually in those blocks is just looking
for the body this is going to I'm going
to add some stuff to the body I'm going
to add some stuff to kind of like
whatever it did that I set up in this
case we need to add it to that
particular element that we're going to
write in the Jupiter notebook and so
you'll need to go through and
essentially find the d3 select change
that usually from body to something that
will let you attached it it's one major
thing the other major thing is that
usually these the blocks will be
referencing an external file usually a
CSV or tab separated file and you'll see
this this sort of thing that says
read read this TSV file and then make
this this is a callback function those
who aren't used to JavaScript this is
totally weird and wacky but the reason
that they do this is because everything
has to be asynchronous so that you the
rest of your page will still render and
whatever so what's happening is though
it's reading the file and then waiting
for it to be done and then once it's
done it's going to use call this
function and that function is then going
to reference that whatever read in this
case that's that's that that variable
name
usually it's data in the box but not
necessarily so that variable name we're
just going to write our data directly to
that variable name so you'll replace all
this stuff with this and this the star
there where the the dollar sign is just
what we use in the template engine to
find and replace that so if you're used
to using the string template which we
are here then that is just the variable
name that you'll write into that and
that's it just one last thing at the
bottom is usually there's a that
function you know had had a closing and
youssef to make sure you and get rid of
the closing okay so once you've done
that so now you have this this you have
the CSS text which you've pulled that's
just the Styles of the thing you have
this JavaScript that you've you've taken
in you've made a template of that you've
made those few modifications that you
need to make to it now once you have
those magic things we have this we're
going to make another template for the
HTML string in this case this so this
ends up being pretty pretty easy to
standardize
so we're going to write some CSX CSS
into the style tab that we're going to
add to the HTML we're gonna add a div
this is going to be the main thing that
will attach things to so instead of
being body in the in the blocks it's
going to be some something that we give
an ID that we can reference and then
we're going to write the JavaScript
this is just the templating engine doing
its thing so you've got we're going to
overwrite that graphic div in the in the
Jas text that we just pulled with the
the so that matches our ID here and the
Python data to be safe will JSON dump
that dump it to a string for most of the
time you don't actually need to do that
you can just write it as a string
version of of the array of dick so that
should work out fine and then there you
go you have yourself a and apologies for
the there you go you have a scatterplot
which you could easily have done in a
lot less hassle with any of our existing
tools but as a pattern yep sometimes so
because you're writing to a you're
writing to a string so if you take the
string version of a verdict it should
work essentially but not always if you
have I can't I'm not even sure why it
doesn't sometimes for me sometimes it
doesn't
where's JSON and dump well will write it
into a form that Jas is for sure gonna
be able to read
yeah actually yeah that would also work
instead of writing to dicts and then
from dick to JSON you can just go
straight to do so yeah
instead of - yeah
there's kind of two parts one is yes we
can reuse parts to this and I'll show
you and the next one how that actually
happens d3 will update things and it's a
bit tricky in our context but it does
the other the other part of that is so
right now instead of writing it in as a
text which is a bit awkward you can you
could do a couple of things when you
could you could just export it to a JSON
file and then have it be read in which
is naturally what the blocks would do
would read in that JSON file you could
do that what would be nicer would be to
kind of more closely approximate what
would happen in a server front end sort
of situation I haven't really triggered
a nice simple way to do that yet but it
would be great essentially if if the
instead of writing into that text string
you can essentially you know have that
out at a create an end point in some
sort of server within Jupiter or so like
some sort within that framework that
then gets hit by the JavaScript I have
yet to figure that it's a smooth
transition but if you have any ideas we
think
maybe I don't know side side thing yeah
any other questions before we move on
but well that that question of can we
use this to update the next topic in the
slides and I'm just going to skip the
slide is it'll go straight into it here
is actually just that so remember that
we've in in in the notebook we're used
to thinking in terms of you make a block
it gives you an output that output falls
below it make another block it gives you
another but everything is kind of
sequential when you're writing
JavaScript and JavaScript is referencing
elements in the Dom it might not
necessarily reference always the one
that you want it'll actually just you
can find any any Dom element and modify
it which is both scary and potentially
amazing so in this case we'll use this
this is another kind of simple bar chart
example but I just want to use it to
show this kind of updating feature so
the same sort of thing we'll use this
the same libraries will reference our or
JavaScript or d3 locally this you'll
recognize from the same thing that
happened last time
hold the CSS straight from that blocks
example same way we did last time the
template is more or less the same as
last time you'll see the same pattern of
changing this data we'll write the data
directly into the string again same
change here changing the divs that we're
referencing and okay this part we'll
come back to in a moment this is the
update part so we have some data we'll
we start with this let's actually for
some
it's clearly open here
okay so just constructed some data in
this case we have four letters each has
a value of one it's pretty amazingly
complicated data it's a small data
problem and now we're going to create a
bar chart with that data and it looks
pretty weird just all ones this is by
the way nominally interactive and that
you can scroll over it that's just comes
free with the blocks that we pulled in
now here's the tricky part of this one
so we we've created a so this is this is
what it this is what it did when it ran
that write it it
it wrote this script into that firstly
created a Dom element called div with a
certain with a certain ID it created
that use this JavaScript to modify that
in particular it's adding an SVG element
and then deciding a bunch of bars or a
bunch of rectangles to that element with
this JavaScript code now the update code
d3 has this this one of the kind of
great parts of d3 essentially is that if
you have a collection of elements and
you and you have some data attached to
that or even if you don't if you add new
if you attach new data to that it will
figure out is there now more data than
there were elements are there less data
than elements and it will kind of give
you this if there's more data you know
have elements that are entering and so
you'll have this this kind of enter this
is a stage terminology of things
entering and exiting and you'll update
with that data so what this is doing is
selecting all of the everything of the
class bar which in this case is these
four bars it's going to select those
rectangles it's going to attach data to
that in this case we're going to kind of
update that data so we're going to
attach new data to that and then we're
going to add a transition that will
change the height of the bar changed
essentially how it looks in the y-axis
with that new data and so what this will
do is once you run this last one I'm
actually just control is that instead of
creating a new Dom element it's just
it's writing a script into the that kind
of Domino and below that is referencing
the one above it so you're actually
going back and you're changing that
other down though that you had so you
can go to town on this all day if you
want and just keep updating that done
which is potentially useful potentially
scary so if you want this to not happen
you have to make sure that your Dom
elements that your IDs are unique every
time you kind of add a new one if you do
want this to happen
you can it's it's kind of nice
okay so that's those are kind of the
main concepts that we need to capture
today's are there any kind of and I'm
just going to go through a bunch of
examples to kind of reiterate on these
things and then show you the little
library that will help you to kind of
encapsulate this so it's not as ugly
when you're kind of write your
javascript in and then we'll talk a
little bit about some pretty awesome
things that are aside from this but
before we go into any of that like are
the basic ideas reasonably clear that
people I like that thumb in the back is
this super slow is everyone kind of
getting bored of this at this point I
see a particular turn of the head so I'm
going to assume that we're doing the
right thing okay so let's just walk
through some of these these cooler
examples which is ultimately what we're
why we're bothering in the first place
right yep yep yeah oh yeah and it
doesn't have that yeah that's part of
the cute little library that does that
yeah that's yeah you'll find in that
repo essentially there's a J's folder
and it has a bunch of examples that are
in that yeah which yeah it's just a lot
nicer usually
okay so let's look through some cool
examples here let's start with ya let
start with this one sure why not
so this was one of the ones that when
you guys were downloading the repo I was
kind of talking through this one is a so
monthly temperature histories from this
is a really really big data set on AWS
if you want to get it there's a blog
post where I went through kind of
filtering that down to something that we
could view but essentially realist will
kind of use this as a as a test case
here in that particular it has it's
referencing some data that's also in
that repo on stations and then for each
station they're a bunch of temperatures
for each month it's all great and then
the way that's the the JavaScript or the
d3 example in this case is setup kind of
asks for the data in a certain format so
there's a lot of kind of munging to get
it in that format and then that's here
I'm actually going to show you this to
you in Firefox because for whatever
reason this particular one works better
in Firefox
usually works better in Fairfax
tipped it up do
so this has a nice you know animates
feature you can pull these things around
oops
probably not useful for your kind of
personal scientific exploration but
potentially useful for something if you
really want to impress the client or
something to be able to kind of give
them this sort of this sort of access to
something like that I should show you
this so in this case the JavaScript I
didn't pull into the code or into the
notebook because it's just far too long
you can see the JavaScript in in the
repo
so in this case it's it's just a lot
more JavaScript than the kind of
examples we've looked at so far which is
part of the kind of joys and downfalls
of d3 is that you can do anything and
sometimes it takes a long time but
essentially the same sort of thing we're
writing into this SVG ID is that the
thing
okay so here's you'll recognize these
sorts of things here so we're writing
the data directly into that into the
Java JavaScript that we'll get ready so
exactly the same pattern just happens to
be hundreds of lines of JavaScript
instead of a few but you can you can
kind of see how that would work there
are plenty of other examples in that yep
yeah no I've been playing around with
that and honestly I don't understand the
details of those two different things
well enough to know when or why I was
hoping that I could loop over display I
can't bloop over HTML but I haven't been
able to and I I should ask Jupiter guys
why they have separate ones but no I
don't think so
yeah thanks for what I meant to clean
all this stuff up button sorry with it
oh let's go to yeah so just an example
you so the same principles you can use X
JavaScript libraries in the same sort of
way so this one is one that I just kind
of recently was was pointed to called
Sigma jeaious if you are doing any sort
of network visualization it's it's a
nice little little package that works
rid of the shelf right off the shelf so
I'm in this case constructing a network
fairly randomly just kind of putting in
nodes and edges so this is what the kind
of node table would look like and what
the edge table would look like and again
you can kind of dig into the it's
referencing this this this external
javascript file
it's overwriting it in the same sort of
way and then you get this this nice
visualization with the handy part of
this one is that you can kind of click
on something and it will show you all
its neighbors they're a bunch of other
kind of
other things you can do if you really
dig into this particular package to look
at things so things that would be tricky
and in kind of our existing libraries
there are there often JavaScript
libraries that already could have set up
to do them I'm gonna leave you to look
at the other the other examples if you
want to get a really big in there's this
the 3d meshing one which is kind of fun
and this is a polyfill one which is is
actually really fun to play with just we
hit that animation button over and over
and over all day in the classic D 3:53
way okay so this leads us to this this
cute little set script that will that
will make it so you don't have to write
all this stuff in in Jupiter and
essentially what this is doing is doing
exactly the same thing as at least that
we kind of walked through step by step
it's just doing it in the library so
I'll show you kind of where that with
these examples so there's a there's a
tiny little Python file that you'll find
in the repo you'll recognize all the
things that it does it does the same
things it's just there it's expecting
all of the CSS that it's going to read
to be in a folder called CSS and is
expecting all of the JavaScript to be in
the folder called J s and then what's I
guess kind of nice about is that instead
of having all those lines of writing
over templates and whatever we could do
it all in this one here it's still
calling the HTML thing we're going to
draw this graph this case is going to
reference basic line J s in the J's
folder read that in overwrite it with in
this case a randomized give label or div
ID so that will make sure that we have
separate div IDs as we go down through
the sheet and then the data that you
want to give it so in this case it has
is expecting
one one over right in the in the text in
the jas that has the name of data we're
going to write it with our particular
there this data in this case called in
data so another kind of super simple
line plots scatter plot you'll recognize
using the same data these ones are kind
of nice the forest directed graphs
and if you the one thing I've been
finding with this is that if you're kind
of playing with this back and forth and
you have your JavaScript in another text
editor you can go and change the
JavaScript so without changing anything
in the in the Jupiter notebook you can
change the JavaScript and then just
rerun this one line so in this case
let's say we wanted to change all these
colors we wouldn't have to do anything
in the
so you could make changes in this in the
JavaScript go back and rerun it kind of
iteratively back and forth so you kind
of keep your JavaScript on one side in
your Python on one side and be able to
go back and forth in this case let's
just make those radiuses really really
big go back and rerun this and voila we
have really giant unfortunately giant
things in there more examples so these
are all just kind of simple examples
pulled from blocks feel free to do the
same the pattern should be pretty easy
to follow yep okay so it's so it's
showing the data just gives nodes that
aren't localized in space at all they're
just giving it just saying I have in
this case 20 nodes 30 nodes and then the
data is defining edges between them so
it's saying that the node one is
connected to node 2 and node 4 and and
then so on kind of down down the list of
which nodes are connected to which nodes
and that's all that's all the data is
saying it's just saying I have a graph
these are the edges these are the nodes
what this force directed graph and you
can this this is a d3 specific kind of
function that you can look through all
the documentation of exactly what it
does essentially what it's doing is it's
taking the nodes and trying to scatter
them but you can imagine the edges kind
of pulling them back together and so
it's it's simulating over time steps
that process whereby things kind of get
pushed and pulled in such a way that
they end up spreading out but I kind of
naturally finding it finding a way that
you can view it that's that you didn't
have to define before so like the X&Y
points we kind of find their own way and
then the same sort of thing happens when
you when you move it
it's just updating based on those kind
of forces that it has what's that's why
it's the first directive yeah it's just
a kind of cute way to visualize
visualize graphs heat maps whatever you
want to get there
okay so we're nice to you everyone sees
how you do this you can go and I can
probably leave you alone now this is one
before we got to get into final
questions and discussion there's what
kind of main more theoretical point that
I'd like to to kind of make I guess and
then show you an example of this so
usually we think of a visualization and
usually our libraries are of the type
where you expect the user to select a
type of graph add some data to it and
then customize it in some way so you now
have you can imagine a library of graph
types for each graph type you have a
number of different parameters and so
usually we kind of think of I'm going to
pick a line chart I'm going to customize
it the way I want on the other hand if
you were a data visualization person in
the front end kind of world or in a
someone who's used to using illustrator
or that sort of thing you probably used
to thinking more in terms of I'm going
to have some lines and some circles and
some whatever and I'm going to have them
rate and the page in a certain way
you're kind of more the level at which
things are standardized or at a much
lower level to give you a much broader
array of possibilities so within that
world instead of thinking of I'm making
us a scatterplot and I'm going to
customize a certain ways you're actually
thinking I'm going to make something
that has a line here and a line here and
it has a bunch of circles circles are
going to be different colors in
different places if you're thinking of
maps you're thinking in the same way you
wouldn't necessarily be thinking in
types you'd be thinking at a much lower
level
and so what using this sort of technique
what you do is let you think at that
sort of level so if you are if you have
something that just doesn't fit any
categories in your visualization at all
this will let you explore that so as an
example of that I'd like to walk you
through there are a bunch of different
tools with which you could make SVG's
just back up one second for those who
aren't d3 users which I know most of us
aren't so SVG is stands for scalable
vector graphic and it's one of the main
things that when d3 makes a graph it
usually it's adding an SVG element and
after that is adding a bunch of of these
elements like circles and lines and
rectangles and whatever so those are all
within this this SVG world SVG is not
necessarily just a like a JavaScript
thing or a d3 thing it's is a way of
describing a vector image more generally
so if you use a vector image making tool
in this case like like illustrator or
there are plenty of other kind of
open-source tools that do that you can
have have at it you can have your your
free rein so let's make in this case
some sort of visualization involving
boxes few of them this presumably means
something to someone somewhere and let's
add a bunch of circles
now let's say the Year project for
whatever reason this was the thing that
you wanted to get across this was the
the important message was was something
like this and that but these these
circles a they mean something and B
they're going to respond to changes in
the data so this is kind of a thing that
you're trying to get across that I would
not know what kind of name of type of
graph I would give this thing but
effectively you can think of this is
what I want to show so if you save this
as a save as an SVG let's call it crazy
okay so now we have this SVG file which
we can open in a text editor which is
pretty nice and you may recognize some
of this as looking a bit like some
things that we might be able to add to
the Dom that's effectively what what d3
would do is it kind of adds things one
at a time we can just go in and add
these ourselves we can write this into
HTML everything except for that first
line you don't want to have that first
line they're saying as XML like
everything else we're gonna copy that
into and I have an example of this
already in here randomize earlier but so
we're gonna write that in there just
this is writing what we just made an
illustrator into the HTML in the jupiter
notebook which is great so let's just
run that and now we have in the jupiter
notebook the thing that we just made an
illustrator which is kind of cool kind
of crazy I don't know sure why you
necessarily want to do that but you
could think of other things you might
want to do that would fit that so to go
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to update that because now we have
it in there we can change we can use d3
or anything else to change that all the
elements in that div so in this case
we're going to I'm going to add some
random random noise is this going to
bounce around and we're going to set the
size of the kind of bounces with this
data in Python so in this case we're
going to say that the most that will go
is 100 pixels in the x-direction and 70
pixels in the y-direction this script
here is just the set interval in
JavaScript is just going to every 100
1000 milliseconds is going to rerun this
thing so we're going to update at random
these circles every 1000 seconds seconds
and we've got a transition the d3
transition that'll make it kind of
smooth so if you click on that you'll
see that your your handmade
Viji is now responding to changes over
time if you want to stop you simply make
it stop
inspector where you were so this this
sort of idea lets you be as you know as
crazy flexible as you could possibly
imagine being and you don't really
expect two types of graphs that's more
or less what I wanted to show you guys
today there isn't really frankly it's
pretty like if you remember one thing is
that the HTML the ipython core display
dot HTML is awesome and this is why
that's pretty much it any questions any
thoughts in terms of like taking a block
yeah beyond the little thing that we
wrote can't afford this and that we use
internally
I haven't haven't seen anyone do that
and I haven't done anything like that
myself it's probably worth doing I do
think that there are better ways to do
this that are kind of more robust and
that would be more it would look more
like the kind of server front-end
interaction that you would expect so I
think that they're kind of if one is to
write a library they they could probably
do it better than what what we've kind
of put together so far but there is a
rudimentary version of what you're
asking is what I think is in that repo
that's that kind of does that to some
extent yeah
yeah yeah no and I should know bouquet
as well will export you know HTML that
you can read in the same way so if you
go do yeah yeah that's true but so if
you if you look at and if you look at
the kind of the MPL d3 export it does do
you know it's a d3 file that you could
then possibly manipulate its it's pretty
verbose I I'm not sure what let's have
you but again those are those are off
the pattern that you're kind of making a
type of graph and then you're you know
modifying it to suit as opposed to
making a d3 visualization and then
modifying it in Python yep
some of the guys in our office use envy
d3 I personally that is a generally a
problem with d3 is that it's so flexible
that it's hard to kind of make it
reusable really the most and I've tried
myself to like make more reusable
versions of it and sometimes you can do
some things that are you kind of like
encapsulate a little bit to it but
almost inevitably you will want that
lower level of functionality that you
that any kind of encapsulation would
would limit to somehow so yeah there are
you know people are have been wrestling
with this for a while and there are some
solutions but I just I usually yeah just
to stick right with the d3 and it
sometimes means you do a bunch of more
copy/paste than you'd want and whatever
but it's yeah it still ends up being
useful okay go I'll stick around for am
often wants to questions you should
check out our blog we've got some really
cool stuff on our blog and yeah - you
have any questions